today's topic Dave Chappelle won the
Mark Twain Award and you did a speech
and I've actually never seen it I like
not knowing what's gonna happen
I like making memories sometimes I do go
this crazy around my colleagues just so
that they can tell their friends I did
it rather than talk about myself just
briefly I want to just talk about my
John Rowe stand-up comedy is an
incredibly American John rrah I don't
think any other country could produce
this many comedians and unbeknownst to
many people in this audience I don't
think there's a pinion that it exists in
this country that is not represented in
a comedy club by somebody each and every
one of you has the champion in the room
what do you think about that you agree
cuz I would probably say that I've seen
all times like we've seen everything in
comedy and it's actually the only plays
that I've seen that that much what do
you mean there's not a lot of places
that I see that that much that's a
different perspective in things like
yeah you won't find that music leave
wait video games even though yeah you're
right I know and you might not be aware
of this cuz we go to open mics we go to
small show so you find everybody
headliners of all kinds go to different
comedy clubs so you may not see them on
TV or on your YouTube but trust me if
you go to enough different comedy clubs
you will hear everything I've seen the
perspective of a lot of people doing
comedy so get yeah that's the only place
I've seen that we watch you guys fight
but when we're together we talk it out I
know comics that are very racist
and I watch them on stage and there was
laughing I'm liking that mo means that
don't get mad at them don't hate them we
go upstairs and have a beer
sometimes I even appreciate the artistry
that they paint their racist opinions
with man it's not that serious the First
Amendment is first for a reason the
Second Amendment is just in case the
first one doesn't work out yo G note
even after saying the first book is the
first one reason the second one is that
I said what I said quickly
thing I like best about tonight was that
so so many people from different parts
of my life like friends that I grew up
with here in DC friends of mine from
Ohio then and now friends of mine from
comedy clubs all the musicians that blew
my mind you guys have no idea how
inspired me I want to give a special
shout-out to my og Tony woods Miles
Davis has a quote
it's one of my favorite Miles Davis said
so much cool but one of the things he
said I was loved he said it took me
years to learn how to play like myself
you know he would watch other musicians
then he would try to play like dizzy or
bird all the guys who were great Tony
woods was my Disney and bird if I was a
Myles I was trying to play like you were
you were the first person I ever saw do
it absolutely right
who feel this he told the truth there's
something so true about this genre when
done correctly that I will fight anybody
that gets a a true practitioner of this
art form his way because I know you're
wrong this is the truth and you are
obstructing it I'm not talking about the
content I'm talking about the art form
do you understand
do we have an agreement when you start
most things in life especially like
things you have no understanding of you
start by imitating what you've seen and
almost any artist will tell you that you
start by imitating even me there's still
a lot of imitation that I used to do
that I'm still in doing as I'm finding
even you of course you go on where did
that pettiness come from rock I don't
like we're deep inside your petty soul I
don't even like that was I got a box to
be you know is biology but all this the
same as you find your own voice a little
bit more and more you start to enjoy it
more because you feel much more at home
on that stage it's a crazy feeling when
you've watched someone perform for a
long time and then you see a development
and you like oh they're finding their
voice no it's a hard thing to explain
tangibly to someone who doesn't do the
art form but like you know it when
someone's found their voice you want to
know how you know because nobody can do
their voice and I'm not talking about
the page or the tonality I'm talking
about the combination of their deliver
their inflection all those different
things that comes together you're like
okay this persons found their unique
voice and there's a joy when you see
someone starting to develop it or having
developed it and killing it while
they're being themselves it's not so
much found yourself as some people
define yourself and themselves really
suck but when you see that person
finding themselves and they're starting
to kill it with that you're like okay I
saw the beginning it did look like that
is you know what's exciting about that
is like you see them develop it so it
gets your juices going to July I wanted
to fill up my dad so becomes like this
healthy form of competition so many
special shout outs
one of the main architects is to come
back in the century my brother and my
mentor the mighty Stan Layton I'd never
dreamed that I would be able to work
with someone as great as you
these last five specials straight fire I
wouldn't want to do another special with
anybody else but you
so each your mother vegetables and live
as long as you can because we're doing a
few more of these business
Neal Brennan your speech made me cry
there is something you really don't
about being able to reward the people
that were loyal to me yeah you know I
mean when you was going through it
there's like when you come up with your
people there's like very few feelings
it's like when we organized our show at
that just for last and I was like Oh big
deal for just being able to give that
opportunity to other people to finally
grace that big statement up and they and
their reaction or reaction like oh my
just to give you guys context like just
for last is like the largest comedy
festival in the world that we were very
fortunate to be given the mainstage you
know and for like 20 thousand people
they let us run our own show and they
gave us the Liberty not only paid the
comics but pick the comics and a lot of
people we give opportunities to never
had it before and more than doing this
show I'll be honest with you guys just
seeing how happy they were to be able to
do it and open that door for them that
[ __ ] felt amazingly even thinking about
right now I get goosebumps a little bit
just because you're like oh I get to
make other people's lives better
especially when I know they're so
deserving you were there you gave me the
support so if I got the opportunity to
give it back to you I'm gonna give it
back and to me it's just normal so it
was really meant for me to put that name
on the paper it was understood that gift
what made total sense that person will
be there but then when you tell that
person when the person sees you in
person is like y'all yeah yo thank you
very much because of such an says you
see them being teary-eyed and stuff like
that you understand the importance of
that is for them as well it's like yeah
ok cool I really wanted to give you bad
because you helped me and I look up and
you're there and when you see that
emotion and that realness and then being
thankful yo cuz you know comedy is a
very unforgiving artform in that like a
lot of people who are deserving and
never really get a shot or never catch a
break
unfortunately just the way it is and
when you get to just regulate that
injustice just a little bit you really
feel like I'm doing something that maybe
it starts to do seconds yeah ok you get
it you get
you get it you get it just we don't know
because we understand it not a popular
thing it's not a pop culture thing and I
know I know who puts it down I know
who's funny funny and it doesn't matter
if it doesn't appeal to you you don't
get it like I do I get it just look let
me be in charge for two seconds yeah all
of that let's go you find your seat of
the chair that's me and don't worry
about them I'm in charge I'm in charge
now so you yeah you get it and we're not
even talking about people we necessarily
like we're also just talking about
people we know deserve it that's it you
know I mean cuz you know if I'm a
comedian standpoint 90% of the time it's
all about meritocracy when we judge each
other does that person kill if they do
pass them on regardless of whether I get
along with them your book them because
my concern is not whether I like them or
not whether or not exactly are we
putting on a good show that's it
and there's too many people right now
involved in comedic decisions who don't
know what they're doing they don't
leverage it with meritocracy you know
okay we need X amount of females X
amount of blacks X amount of this X
amount of that excellent no are you good
or not let's go and when you we kind of
picked them in the bottom barrel a that
was trying to fight they way they're
hungry they're hungry so you like no no
no no you you yeah yeah I know you lose
100% that's great because it remind me
of all those hard days of work and all
that money I never got for it the other
real special shout-out I got to make cuz
none of this would have been possible in
any level without this person is my
mother
my mother
[Applause]
my mom mom mom you have no idea when I
put this woman through
if you have just given birth to me there
would have been more than enough with
the fact that she raised me and raised
me well he had a real oral tradition in
our house I knew the word griot when I
was a little boy a griot was a person in
Africa who was charged with keeping the
stories of the village everyone would
tell gril the stories and they would
remember them all so that they could
tell future generations when they got
old they'd tell him to someone else and
they'd say in Africa when a griot dies
it's like a library was burnt down and
my mother used to tell me before I ever
thought about doing , she said you
should be a griot and she's filming with
every story of black life you know she's
educated in African American Studies and
she would let me understand the context
that I was being raised in I'm being
raised in a hostile environment that I
have to tame but Tyler was 14 years old
I was in nightclubs mastering an adult
world she's terrified crack epidemic was
going on and my mother would hear
gunshots outside and be scared to death
maybe it's my son but early in my career
if you remember mom he used to sit in
the club with me she'd do a full day of
work he'd be back there fall asleep just
waiting for me to go on she would watch
my show every night do you know how long
that car ride is home
how many of you have ever heard your
mother say jokes were a little too much
tonight son
[Applause]
I was a soft kid I was sensitive I cry
easy and I would be scared to fistfight
my mother used to tell me this thing I
don't even know if you remember but you
said this to me more than once
you said son sometimes you have to be a
lion so you can be the lamb you really
are I talked this like a lion I'm not
afraid of any of you when it comes word
to word I will gab with the best of them
just so I can chill and be me and that's
why I love my art form because I
understand every practitioner of it
whether I agree with them or not I know
where they're coming from they want to
be heard they got something to say
there's something they noticed they just
want to be understood love this genre it
saved my life
so tonight my I would like to honor you
in a very special way that I cannot do
on my own but because now I land with
great and influential friends I like to
ask my man Thundercat to come out on
stage Thundercat the mighty mos def
washington-dc thank you very much for
giving me a home and a place to start
today is officially a Dave Chappelle day
in Washington DC's the mayor declared
last night so in the future or Dave
Chappelle day I asked everyone who
wishes to celebrate it to make one
incredible memory for themselves and or
somebody else thank you very much
good night that's a ton of speech I
wanna give that's how I want to talk to
people that's what I want to move people
when I talk though I'm not him I wanna
do it like me he inspires me to do
something that moves people I don't want
to move people like him I want to be new
people at me but I want to move people
you know someone I find I don't want to
emulate everything he does is just
inspired me to when I talk to someone I
moved in that's pretty much more I
wanted to say yeah I don't want to be
exactly am I can yeah I don't
that's good you have your own voice and
you shouldn't want to be like him
because you never know yeah yours might
have shine it might be completely
different it might have people in a
different way so you got to find that
Avenue for you yeah that's pretty much
it but that's that's a great speech no
no flat flat I love it what did you like
about the speech how much it was real
I felt the realness that's why I move it
was real it came from the heart it was
really real
no give me something like that I'm a
light this is a great up and I'm gonna
tell you a story I love the idea that
despite all of our differences we can
find ways to co-exist and talk and be
understood and I think that kind of idea
is what I live for
there's plenty of people on this planet
that I really disagree with but when
were able to engage in civil discussion
when I'm able to better understand them
after one discussion I'm not saying
we're to come to a consensus I'm not
gonna say there's gonna be a resolution
but if I can leave something
understanding you just a tad bit better
then I feel like things are better
because I got to see a little bit more
of like the human in you you know what
I'm saying I got to understand why you
are the way that you are and it helps me
to empathize with you more and so I
think one thing that was the message he
was preaching and and I'm all for that
and I'm happy to see the redemption
story you know just because me being a
fan his way back in the day but then
hearing all the terrible things that
people have said about him and me not
wanting to believe it just to see
everything come
Circle didn't there's something really
great about seeing someone be authentic
see someone be true to their values and
to see them win you know in a world
where we tell people you got a sacrifice
your values and all this stuff all the
time it's just great that we are valuing
authenticity and honesty and integrity
so much today and that to me makes me
optimistic about the future I believe I
mean that you know I do feel that way
because you said that in my meeting
about I believed it's crazy is my mom
mom man like my mom the mom it's
changing the way she views how you find
success in life like all those old ideas
that our parents had about like you have
to do it this way we're changing that
yeah imagine like I have to praise my
parents like like my parents are like
okay so what do you do in life how do
you pay your bills yeah well yeah mom I
Wow I was where did you get a diploma
for that I I did I
I just you know I read a lot of books a
lot of articles why people are listening
to you but then she saw the just for
laughs she saw the cookout my dad's like
oh okay he's just a mother my dad's
toasted right are you happy are you good
yes I'm yeah my mom when she saw like
she was like oh there's a lot of birth
to the first part oh there's a lot of
people it's really fun I'm like I'm like
well yeah wait mom is about to and she
saw I saw her face was just like the
next thing when she was like oh there
was a lot of people laughing at your
jokes I was like yeah that's what I do I
still don't understand but I get it yeah
so their perception of what success is
switch because before you had to have
certain brand name car you had to have
this kind of diploma this kind of job I
mean this kind of money and I was kind
of different I think all people are I
saw your son I sign your son as I say
I'm saying to your mom yeah
I saw your son don't your mom bet even
though you bastard not my mom today is
where Dave Chappelle's mom was back in
the eights in terms of her perspective
oh yeah
and people might be like that's so
backwards I voted I'm like sometimes
humanity's progress is slow we all
progress at different paces she was
that's why I'm optimistic about the
future because even if some people's
progress is slower than others I really
feel like as a race we are moving
forward and I think that's why I'm also
excited about the prospect of raising my
own children I said the world that I see
today despite all the problems that
people claim I'm like I see a lot of
amazing things and yeah I think that's
what that speech filming with yeah man
that's pretty much it for today's video
if you guys got any comments or ideas or
thoughts on the whole thing we want to
hear your comments below because we want
to see what you have to say otherwise
subscribe and
[Music]